(sirènes)
- L'humanité a les deux pieds
au bord du précipice climatique
mais refuse de le reconnaître,
conclut le rapport du GIEC,
un groupe d'experts
internationaux mandatés
par l'ONU pour faire le point
sur les changements climatiques.
Près de 200 États ont entériné
le rapport de 3000 pages
présenté par le GIEC.
Pour ceux qui en doutaient
encore, il confirme que l'humain
est le principal responsable
de la hausse de la température
mondiale provoquée par
les gaz à effet de serre
et des conséquences
catastrophiques
qu'elle entraîne.
ALAIN BOURQUE,
DG, Consortium OURANOS
- Les changement du climat
sont en train de transformer
le climat de l'ensemble
des régions de la planète.
C'est de plus en plus rapide,
ça va s'intensifier,
ça affecte l'atmosphère,
l'hydrosphère, les océans.
- En ce moment, on observe
une hausse moyenne de
la température sur Terre
de 1,1 °C par rapport
à l'ère pré-industrielle.
Au rythme actuel d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre,
on atteindra le seuil
de l'accord de Paris, 1,5°,
autour de 2030, soit
dix ans plus tôt que prévu.
En l'absence de gestes
concrets, disent les experts,
on pourrait même dépasser
les 2, 3, voire 4 °C
d'ici la fin du siècle.
Lors du Sommet sur le climat
qui se tiendra en novembre
prochain, à Glasgow, en Écosse,
les pays participants essaieront
donc de s'entendre sur les
prochaines cibles à atteindre.
Mais si les changements
d'habitudes de vie devront être
radicaux et avoir lieu dans un
avenir très rapproché, explique
le rapport, il est encore
possible de limiter les dégâts.
- Heureusement, il y a
quand même des signaux positifs,
c'est-à-dire que le rapport
présente toute une série
de scénarios que l'on peut
réussir à atteindre de facon
à réussir à contrôler l'ampleur
du changement climatique.
- La dernière fois que
les niveaux de gaz à effet
de serre étaient aussi élevées
sur Terre, souligne le document,
c'était il y a
3 millions d'années.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, M